I welcome to this video back-to-back
game the same opponent again step by
step yeah i'm going to transpose into a
king's indian or what what now and the
norwegian defense no Knight f6 is the
Norwegian defense nothing great but has
been played by Magnus once now it takes
lots of time and at the end probably
will transpose to a king's indian anyway
no early night c6 line
yeah this is a playable line for black
kids it's not really good but it's also
not terribly bad it's a one of those now
you can play but you shouldn't bet your
house on it it's very often leads to
something like that benoni type of
structure or widest just somewhat better
join gain the space young oops sorry I
have some some sneaky I'm nighty for a
half so we want to sacrifice a PCM
interesting maybe okay I need to do this
anyway after f three years specialist
trapped I wonder does she have some
syntactic here maybe he has but I will
you he needs to show me ah ah ok can
take yes I overlooked ok the idea is
clear rookie through Bishop before but I
forgot that you can take mmm no that's
awful
ah yeah I should have taken a bit more
time it's not exactly difficult to see
so okay we'll just need to continue to
play a bone down
you
hmm
it's just a pawn and not a position
that's also clearly the case rook d3
this Bishop f3 and it's very differently
rookie aid
yeah that's actually resigned about this
position no but okay I can play place
someone's check
check
maybe it's doing something stupid in the
technical phase of the game but it's
very unlikely it's just very bad for
wine
not saying that he made some mistake but
i'm glad that i have got one pair of
rocks off with 22 looks it was even it
was even more difficult for me with two
rooks the big pressure
check
maybe it get get one threatened in this
game with Bishop d3 now what you can
always hope for is that that maybe um
get get a pawn somewhere and then have
some saving chances in the rook endgame
yeah my Ruca is active it's um it's
still still losing probably but it was
worse now c 5 + h 5 is hanging Michael
f4 check check
check-check time warning I don't really
know what is doing him but I clearly had
more problems earlier so
check check check check
I can just take no I could have just
taken them whatever
I know I spoiled it again after he
pleaded aah chak I really got very close
to a draw here from this totally lost
position come on white resides yeah
there is this is engine jackie was very
close to the only draw shiny very cool
check check check John yeah it's still
losing here with the edge point but I
don't know check yeah I know at the end
it's a deserved loss I mean I it's clear
that no the computer is not even Bishop
g5 yeah Bishop g5 but what what is the
big point of this I can check a check
here
this is the comp line leading to to a
winning attack for black which is quite
strange very weird yeah I was uh I was
thinking about Bishop g5 but I thought
it wouldn't lead to anything yeah well
anyway overlooking the whole idea of
knight takes Bishop takes d5 deserves a
loss in this game okay wow thanks for
watching